[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con nos acompaña
a jonathan box director de la fundación
para la libertad de prensa en colombia
en las últimas jornadas hemos conocido
numerosas denuncias de la restricción a
la libertad de expresión e información
por un lado según confirma la
organización británica net blogs se
produjo un corte de la señal telefónica
y de internet en la ciudad de cali las
operadoras y la comisión de regulación
de las comunicaciones del país afirman
que se debió a un problema técnico oa un
colapso de la red por su uso masivo
durante las protestas pero que está
pasando señor boca
muy buenos días sí yo creo que estamos
en un punto como hemos visto en otros
países cuando sucede en este tipo de
manifestaciones también y es que hay
mucha preocupación por lo que está
ocurriendo frente a internet y al acceso
no y esas dos preocupaciones una tiene
que ver con la infraestructura que es
precisamente lo que estás comentando y
son estos bloqueos que pueda haber que
bien puede ser como mencionan y como así
lo han explicado las compañías y la
comisión nacional de regulación que
puede deberse a el colapso por el
tráfico en la red o algún daño puntual
de uno de los puntos de que da acceso a
la conexión sin embargo también pues por
supuesto esto toca ser muy transparente
y poder tener los materiales suficientes
y la evidencia suficiente para saber qué
es así y que no se trata por el
contrario de una orden expresa para
apagar para hacer un shot down de
internet en un punto específico del país
o pues
a nivel nacional a nivel nacional por
otro lado este jueves decenas de
usuarios reportaron la imposibilidad de
acceder
stories de instagram y a las
retransmisiones en directo en directo de
las protestas ustedes se reunieron con
facebook que es la empresa propietaria
de instagram para abordar la cuestión
que les respondieron
exacto ese es el otro punto que nos
preocupan hoy es la censura o los
problemas que se puedan enfrentar ya por
decisiones de las plataformas y ahí
especialmente el miércoles y el jueves
hubo muchísimos casos de denuncias que
les a los usuarios les estaban bajando
el contenido en instagram sobre eso
facebook nos dijo que estaban trabajando
lo más rápido posible para poder
instalar una especie de filtro que para
que el algoritmo no bajara el contenido
sino que por el contrario advirtiera que
se trata de un contenido sensible pues
porque por supuesto tenemos que estar
claros que la manifestación está
haciendo violenta hay agresividad y pues
eso es lo que se refleja en los vídeos
pero eso no quiere decir que los
usuarios estén haciendo de ninguna
manera pues apología o estén
incentivando el odio no entonces este es
el tipo de problemas que ya se han
enfrentado en otros países y que lo
estamos viendo en este momento y que por
supuesto limita mucho la información y
lo que está publicando la gente ayer un
medio de comunicación cuestión pública
un medio digital
estaban en un facebook live y le bajaron
ese contenido entonces una situación que
apremia mucho para que la compañía dé
una respuesta positiva lo más pronto
posible tanto ustedes como reporteros
sin fronteras reportan el ataque al
ejercicio periodístico durante las
manifestaciones que lo que lo motiva se
ha incrementado en los últimos años
lo que estamos viendo en estos momentos
es unos ataques el número de ataques
contra periodistas no tiene precedentes
no llevamos a 90 periodistas que han
sido agredidos en la última o los
últimos ocho días y esto es un número
altísimo y lo que termina enviando es un
mensaje más amplio de censura a la
prensa en general y de intimidación para
quienes quieren ir a cubrir a los
periodistas los periodistas nos lo
manifiestan y tienen mucho miedo y mucha
preocupación de ir a cubrir lo que está
pasando y cada vez se limitan más y
hacen un ejercicio pues que es
prácticamente registro y no tienen
muchas posibilidades y margen de
maniobra de poder cubrir mejor no y lo
hacen hasta cierto tiempo limitado
entonces pues todo esto configura un
escenario de falta de garantías y pues
por supuesto como digo de censura
ustedes son una de las organizaciones
que han pedido a la corte suprema que
declara desacato de la sentencia que
protege el derecho a la protesta que qué
consecuencias esperan que desencadene su
solicitud
pues el mensaje es que esto no se ha
cumplido que el protocolo que estaba
establecido no lo están cumpliendo ni
las alcaldías las administraciones
locales pero tampoco el gobierno
nacional ni las entidades de control y
esta es una herramienta sumamente
valiosa que debe garantizar el derecho a
la protesta pacífica señor voz pues
muchas gracias por todo este análisis
por la información que nos ha dado en
france 24 de ustedes gracias por su
sintonía continúen con nosotros que hay
más
[Música]